il fallait bien un accord pour régler
ces chamailleries commerciales entre la
chine et les usa
depuis des mois elle avait des
répercussions sur toute l'économie
mondiale
alors que tout ce qu'ils ont dans cet
accord déjà la chine s'est engagée à
apporter plus de produits américains
sûrs deux ans 200 milliards de dollars
de plus par rapport à 2010 est en
échange trump lui s'engage à ne pas
mettre en place de nouvelles taxes
douanières il tend maintenant c'est
qu'ils sont déjà en place
du moins jusqu'à la phase 2 de l'accord
oui on vous n'avez pas dit cette
première signature n'était que la phase
la phase 2 elle promet d'être très
compliqué les etats unis ont en ligne de
mire des subventions massives de l'état
chinois à ses industries considérant
cela comme de la concurrence déloyale au
niveau international preuve également ce
qu'il considère comme le vol par la
chine de la propriété intellectuelle des
entreprises américaines et demande que
des dispositions juridiques
contraignantes soient mises en place
pour y mettre fin
harek genre des grosses amendes bien
dissuasive bref c'est pas encore gagné
un premier pas a été fait enfin reste à
savoir si la chine dont l'économie subit
un gros ralentissement jouera bien jeu
et si elle signera aussi et à face d'eux
de la corne
[Musique]